Speaker 1: Let's speak to some more
people via the David Pakman show Discord,
which you can find at David Pakman dot
com slash discord. We're going to go next
to Miles in Bay City, Michigan. Miles, welcome.
Speaker 2: Hello? Mr. Pacman, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Just barely. If you
can speak up, it would be great.
Speaker 2: Okay. So it's all coming
through because that's a little bit better.
So a quick question for you. This is kind of
relevant to about employment because there's you
know, there's a lot of places where it's like, oh,
we can't find workers. Well, well, most of these
jobs, they only offer part time. I can't help but
want to look at some of these managers and stuff
and just like. And you're you're not offering
full time and benefits. Like, I can't help but
ultimately look at some of these people. It's like
instead of looking for, say, five part timers,
I have three full timers. I can't feel like that.
In the end. It's like it's going to cost the
business roughly the same, but you're going
to have someone there to run the business
and all that, and it should function as intended.
You know, they'll get people to fill those jobs
that they give, you know, you know, they offer a
full time job and benefits. I mean, I just can't
help but feel like that's just when I see some of
that stuff like that. It's just like the answer's
right in front of you and they're not taking it.
Speaker 1: I generally speaking, I agree. I mean,
one of the things about full employment
and we are really close to full employment,
I know right wingers will say, oh, but people
filed for unemployment last month. That always
happens. But when you have 3.5% unemployment,
the jobs report came in at double the number of
new jobs that was expected. We are close to full
employment in this country. One of the things is
employers are going to have to fight for employees
to some degree, particularly in these minimum wage
or close to minimum wage jobs. So, yeah, I think
that that is it. It's just supply and demand to
a certain degree.
Speaker 2: Hmm.
Very interesting. Anyway. I just I was on my mind.
Speaker 1: All right. Thank you so much for the
call. I appreciate it. Yeah. This is a good point.
And it's experiencing it in some sectors, but
not in others. And it's because of what we might
kind of colloquially call the quality of the job.